If you're new to Google
Cloud Platform, you might
be wondering, what
are the best resources
I should know about to
help me get started?
There's a lot out there
and sometimes it's
difficult to know
where to begin.
So today I'm going to take
you on a lightning quick tour.
Google recently
launched a new course
in collaboration
with Udacity to help
you learn the components
that make up App Engine.
There's lots of video
content in the course
as well as practical
hands-on coding
exercises and an
integrated discussion forum
so you can learn as part
of a growing community.
Every year Google holds
Google I/O in San Francisco
and this year's I/O included
some awesome code labs
that anyone can
follow, including
two labs for Google
Cloud Platform
to help you get Google
Compute Engine and App Engine.
Actually, I/O has
lots more resources
to help you learn about
using Google technologies
and most of the tours
are available for you
to watch online.
Google has organized collections
of these tours by product
and you can find
lots of index talks
on services like Big
Query or Compute Engine.
Once you start working
on your own projects,
there's a bunch of useful
tools that can really
help with understanding all of
the various API and parameters
that are available.
My favorite of these is
the powerful API Explorer
which allows you to list,
interact, and experiment
with all of the available
APIs in your browser.
One of the trickiest aspects
of working with most APIs is
the use of OAuth and Google has
put together another Playground
specifically aimed
at helping debug
the sometimes
complex issues that
can arise around this protocol.
Finally, there's also a third
Playground designed especially
for Google Cloud Platform
that provides you
with a place to
experiment and get
to know the various
services from the comfort
of your browser without having
to install or modify anything
on your machine.
When you feel a bit more
confident with the various
services, I highly recommend
you check out the detailed
documentation on
cloud.google.com/docs.
You can find articles and
tutorials on everything
from mobile apps, big data,
gaming solutions and much more.
You'll also find links
to lots of sample code
on GitHub hosted under the
Google Cloud Platform account.
Actually, there are quite
a lot of these repositories
on GitHub, so Google
built an easy to use
front end that makes
finding that sample
code you're looking
for a breeze.
You could search by technology,
programming language,
or solution.
Sooner or later you're going
to run into a problem or issue
that you'd like some help with.
It might be a bugging or code,
a performance issue, or maybe
you just need some help
understanding that new feature
everyone is raving about.
For more technical
questions where
you want to share
some of your code,
I recommend heading over to
Stack Overflow where you'll
find lots of experienced
developers and Google engineers
contributing help.
Just use these tags to find
the most relevant answers
to your questions.
For more general advice about
which design patent or library
to use, check out the official
Google Cloud Platform community
on Google+.
I often find that new developers
can find the product life
cycle takes a little
time to get used to.
The Google Cloud Platform
product life cycle
consists of a series of stages.
Early on in the development
of new products and features,
Google might offer
an alpha release.
At this point,
developers can ask
for one of their
apps or projects
to be white listed to
try out the new feature.
For alpha, Google often
signs up developers
to a dedicated
Google group where
they can ask questions, make
suggestions, and raise issues.
Further into the product
development life cycle,
Google usually
offers a beta stage
where anyone can use
the new features.
At this stage, you won't find
a service level agreement,
or SLA, and you
should expect to see
some open outstanding issues.
Next, comes general
availability,
where developers can expect
full support, documentation,
and an SLA.
Eventually, some services
need to be retired
and these periods
are typically covered
by something called
a deprecation policy.
During this period,
you should plan
to migrate those features
or aspects of your code
that will be affected
by the deprecation
before the end of the period.
The best place to keep up
to date with the latest
announcements and news
around Google Cloud Platform,
including upcoming events, new
features, and deprecations,
is the official blog.
You can also sign up
to a monthly newsletter
to have the latest news
sent right to your inbox.
Finally, there are a couple
of great annual events
to look out for.
Every year, many of
the Google Developer
Groups, or GDGs,
around the world
host community-run
DevFests that include
talks, code labs,
and hackathons.
You'll find many Googlers
and Google Developer Experts
taking part in these
events and it's a great way
to get to know your local
developer community.
Many GDGs also host
events to celebrate
Google I/O in their
local communities
with live viewing parties,
speaking sessions and product
demos.
You can learn more
about these at
developers.google.com/events.
So remember, the
community is made
possible through
the participation
of awesome developers
just like you.
I highly recommend checking
out your local Google Developer
Group to see how you can
contribute and have fun.
You can also take part by
helping other developers online
using any of the ways
I've described above.
I can't wait to meet
you online or in person
and hear what you're building
on Google Cloud Platform.